hey guys how's it going welcome back to
my kitchen today we are making a massive
Oreo cookie now I tried this once before
but it didn't really work out so well so
I thought that I would go about this a
different way I got these really cool
silicon molds and we're gonna try that
out and see if this works I found this
recipe online and there was a problem
with the recipe because it was all in
grams so I have to convert them to
things that I can understand so let's
get started here's the things that we're
gonna need to intagram zuv soft butter
250 grams of dark brown sugar 2 large
eggs 2 tsp vanilla extract 1/2 teaspoon
of sea salt 200 grams of plain flour 50
grams of cocoa 1 teaspoon baking powder
let's piece my hair it's cool so now
we're gonna be so proud and butter
together in you go time to mix oh it's
not like a cake - okay so our sugar and
butter is mixed together nicely now
we're gonna put in 2 eggs continue to
mix
okay that looks fantastic so now we're
gonna mix in the rest of our stuff let's
mix this up real good and you go bud
nice slow okay when you turn this up
because I don't have time for this oh
yeah that's perfect so now it's time to
make our cookies these are the molds
that I got I got them on Amazon I'll put
a link in the description if you would
like to get them as well just this is
this is it it's just a big cookie mold
I'm concerned though because this text
is so small and there's so much detail
that I don't know how that's gonna work
out so I guess we'll find out very
shortly see what happens
now let's get this all spread out to the
sides I'm gonna bake these on here
because these are kind of flimsy so I
want to be able to easily take them in
and out of the oven
pre-heat your oven to 350 and bake for
about 25 to 30 minutes I would
definitely check on them and then let
them sit for about an hour after they're
done now it's time to make our Oreo
cookie icing we've got our butter we've
got our powdered sugar we've got art he
should appear vanilla extract Oh fancy
so I'm not really sure the measurements
because again these were all in grams
and my conversion skills mmm not that
good so we're just gonna kind of
guesstimate which is my favorite way of
doing things which is the complete
opposite that you should do with baking
Jam the same there I probably should use
the sand mixer but now I'm here so
Amarna you just I'm just gonna do what I
do I'm gonna use my best kitchen
judgement on how much I need maybe we
should start with a cup and a half and
see where that gets us because you can
always add more put in just a little bit
of this cheese I feel like I should
double this this isn't gonna be enough
for my taste
hey can you do me one of these spatulas
please
thank you what have I done I messed it
up this is not icing maybe it is I mean
I guess when you think about like I'm
not making cake icing this is Oreo
cookie icing it looked like little tiny
balls
no I'm receiving a phone call from
Morocco leave me alone I'm clearly busy
to be fair this actually feels like the
consistency of like the Oreo cookie
because of icing sugar I'm almost out of
it though and then four to five
tablespoons of coffee cream 18% coffee
cream this might be you know we could do
let's put a little listen yeah I think
that's what we needed
oh my gosh this smells lovely maybe I
need to switch my beaters it's
definitely a tools problem it's not a me
problem thank you
maybe I need a smaller bowl blame the
tools Justine I'm gonna give it a just a
taste
oh my gosh I'm so happy with how this
hurt this this was the key this was the
key
Nick you're a genius yeah this looks
pretty good now here's the real test how
are the cookies gonna turn out because
that is questionable
I was very skeptical while I was putting
these into the pan but I'm thinking that
they might be okay I'm a little bit
worried though because I don't know if
they got inside of these crevices or not
the only way to find out is I guess just
go for it
so let's see I put so much spray on this
okay
well you know there's a little bit left
inside that's okay this looks good this
looks good and I'm happy so far there is
definitely a lot left inside but you
know I don't really know how they
expected this to work out that is some
very very tiny font okay here is our
Oreo there's still the top of it but
we're gonna ice this first and just wow
I don't know I can't wait to taste this
I think this may be the first time I'm
excited to taste something that I've
made so let's hope it's actually good
the
is such a thick consistency because it's
not like normal cake icing its Oreo
icing we're gonna use all of this this
is double triple stuff and here we have
it now it's time to place the top cookie
on fingers crossed that it's gonna work
out because so far things have been
going very well oh my gosh I'm so
nervous please come out and be beautiful
you know just like dropping on yes here
it is it looks like it actually worked
out okay time for the placement mmm my
goodness did I just make something
successful go to your calendar right now
and mark today as the day we're just een
has finally succeeded at baking
something awesome
[Music]
okay find a good spot okay ready oh my
god
pull car 3 have you ever seen me this
happy the only time you've ever seen me
this happy is when I have a new Apple
product Nick get over here get over here
immediately wait I have a question
though
hmm you said you're gonna eat it like I
regular Oreo so we need to milk it small
I don't have any meal not anymore
a bucket wait I was joking that no we
gotta get milk I think we need to dip it
in a milk animal hold on wait don't
touch it don't touch it cause I'll know
because I'll see the footage you're not
logged up is manifest we need to get
milk why would you like to take a bite
first yes please okay good then what
just I've been sitting back there in the
novel and then I'm going to order milk
do you want yeah maybe yeah is gonna be
so great we're gonna dip it I want to
order some milk on Amazon right now
how many gallons do you think two
gallons yeah I think she would do it I'm
so excited oh my god I know it's
incredible what you can't have anymore
one little one please no yeah you can
have one more right right you're allowed
just a little we have to dunk it in the
milk thank you enjoy well guys thank you
so much for watching we hope you guys
enjoy this leave me some comments below
and what you'd like to see me make next
and if you did enjoy this and if you are
proud of me today marks a national
holiday so every day on this day it will
be Justine did something right day so if
you want to celebrate my special day use
hashtag national Justine did something
right day I'll see you guys on Twitter
and Instagram and Facebook and wherever
else it is that you guys use social
media things
we've got our milk we've got our cookie
now it is officially an Oreo party so
let's take a dunk see what this party's
all about mmm displacement
[Music]
[Applause]
it just feels weird
[Music]
hey well I guess I'll just oh my god
it's so incredible I'm so happy right
now
[Music]
yeah when anybody asked me ever again
Justine what do you do for fun I'll send
them this jiff I'll see you guys later
that's a
[Music]
you